the time is night people I've begun to
receive Facebook tier anime memes on my
timeline instead of giving in to the
Deep despair that is being served these
posts let's fact check here first up
we've got Goku and things are already
way off Goku has three main villain
defeats Sergeant Black Demon King
Piccolo and then Kid Buu then we've got
trunks who actually has two main villain
defeats with both Frieza and cell not to
mention the Majin bust off in Dragon
Ball super if we're counting those then
we've got Gohan who has two
more on
only main villain Gohan has ever
defeated is perfect cell frieza's one
defeat is valid so no notes there and
then Vegeta at zero well yeah poor guy
all in all I have spent too long now
thinking about this shitty Facebook meme
I am going to cleanse my palette by
going outside and telling children to
stay off my lawn